Oh hi everyone my name is Tamara
chambers
I'm Jim Jerez and this is Tamara just
saw no so Jim that's why I've tagged
along well you just got done seeing
overlord and I have not been so tense
okay in such a good way in so huh yeah I
think we're both kind of crashing now I
feel I feel like completely drained from
like yeah just feeling the intensity for
like two hours or you know like BR being
like tensed up and I put yeah in the
best possible way it's the new
corrections Hank JJ Abrams he produced
it okay yeah it's basically Wolfenstein
yeah I went into it super excited and we
were walking around talking is like oh
we're gonna go see overlord and everyone
was like oh it's getting good reviews so
weird and I thought like well sure I
isn't everybody excited to see this
movie yeah yeah I didn't hear much about
it other than seeing the trailers yeah
in my mind I thought it was just gonna
be like a really intense Wolfenstein it
I think that's exactly what it was yeah
absolutely I had my expectations were
met I think like it was exactly what I
wanted to get out of it yeah which was
great and in some ways like it was like
I think it was a few things I was saying
like I would have liked to see just a
little more of this but there was enough
other things till I kind of filled in
the parts that might have been missing
there i was like no i didn't care like
it was yeah if the movie itself flowed
so well the characters were great like
the action was so palpable is this like
as a war movie it's super awesome and
intense yeah and then like when the
horror stuff or like you know the
suspense kind of kicks in then it's like
that's amazing to like it's such a great
blend it's so yeah yeah you're saying
like if you went in not knowing that
there's the horror aspect you just be
blown away by this incredible war movie
and the first sequence when they're on
the plane anywhere needs to take their
dive into their area
to be in to take down the church it was
the most nerve-wracking horrifying plane
sequence I've ever seen in a war movie
we said you thought I said it you feel
like you're on one of those for do ya
right you'd be like oh like this needs
removing
yes kind of you know you can feel a
concussion of blasts and stuff going on
yeah yeah yeah it's super intense it's
like I was it's kind of like the aerial
version of Saving Private Ryan when
they're getting off I mean they're like
on the boats and stuff like that it was
just like you know yeah so yeah so
amazing war movie and then you start
getting into like the disgusting science
hostel in scientists it was so great
it's so creepy it was so I guess I was
gonna say there was a sense of humor
there was no humor in the movie right
right
but like especially at the end with like
the massive like boss fight you get a
sense of like it's fun maybe that's not
the word no I think yeah no I think it
is I I had like a blast legends movie
and that was like what I wanted like the
characters were worse the stereotypes
that you see in every type of this movie
like or a movie or kind of horror movie
you know yeah um I didn't care it was
like knowing or like all right well I
know who the characters are yeah and
you're you're immediately thrust into
you know no time for a beginning yeah no
time establishing the characters and
they're so good at being those Carrie
yes
no but all the performances are great
yeah yeah like the the lead the evil
Nazi whatever like it's so great and
creepy and stuff for all of like the
intense moments that are like super
action and like super thrilling the some
of the very slow kind of like unsettling
moments our Sartre are done so well also
yeah where
yeah there's such a great blend between
those elements like it takes a walk the
first half of the movie is is during the
war
basically and then you start getting
hints of the those elements of like the
evil science you know the Nazis are
experimenting and stuff and the war
stuff is so intense and unsettling that
like and I wasn't like just get to the
castle or get to those people not me get
you there like yeah yeah yeah I would
have been so fine to watch a full movie
of these war characters going through
the war yeah yeah and then you get like
this horror aspects that are truly scary
it's like the true definition of
horrific like it or I'm in such a fun
way is so flat about myself tense but
also like grinning from ear to ear I
feel like I've been wanting to see this
movie too for so long even before I saw
the trailer like I wasn't on camera I'm
like I'm like a fan of the whole like
zombie Nazi kind of genre loved it and
and I've never seen it done really
really well and this was like the first
one that was like yes this is what I've
been waiting to see I could see how this
genre could get very poorly made yeah
and I think you like like the fact that
it has a smell like GG tiramisu never
has a big budget behind it you know yeah
but it doesn't lend itself to being a
big-budget movie like it doesn't feel
like a big-budget movie in that sense
yeah the sets that they were using
amazing there's one point where they
come into the village and they've just
captured the girl and they're like bring
us to safety and it looks like if you
guys have played the even within it
looks like the beginning of that when
you're going up into the castle of that
and it's so beautiful did you find this
I don't know where are you filming this
movie it's amazing and then like the
actors are great like the Kurt Russell
son right well I just like hopefully I'm
like I didn't know that he was
it was like this guy's reminds me of
Kurt Russell like you know so he has a
Kurt Russell about him yeah yeah I just
might think I'm like this gotta be like
a Greek like Snake Plissken they were
gonna remake it this guy should be the
two leads yeah we're just really
everybody's performance was salad like I
was like a super bought into everybody's
performance everybody did a great job
yeah and like you said like it's not
really funny like there are like comedic
moments but there are but it is like fun
like you're kind of comedic moments yeah
and the horror thickness that's not in
the sequences is it so outrageous yeah
that you can only really just like have
fun with it yeah because it's so it's a
really difficult movie to watch in like
a really great way it's very its graphic
and it's intense and terrifying and so
it's riveting like where you're still
like you're staring at the movie because
you don't want to miss anything a second
of it yeah yeah like all my notes I
couldn't even read them we're driving
over here because just like but like do
you find like fun in the horror they
very easily could have been like well
that's because it's kind of like an
outrageous kind of concept in everywhere
we know whatever it would be easy to
make it sort of campy and like the
acting to be like a little like wink at
the camera but because all the
characters played it so straight like it
kind of made it even even better I don't
know yeah there was this like it was
like everybody's given like a hundred
percent yeah it is shot dark and
sequences it is shot very much like kind
of a grindhouse movie where some of its
like it's really like you're some scenes
are really dark and in shadow and it's
super gritty and everything's wet and
yeah yeah you know has that gritty on
easy feel like you know like well then
set design
and after our directions something that
was great going in I just wanted to see
some creepy-ass Nazi experiments okay
you get a great scene with that the
creatures that they make are so
compelling there's like one chase scene
especially between the lead woman and
one of these creatures who she was great
to me there is so often like with what
the female lead they feel like they're
just pigeon-holed in there because they
need to be in there but like hers didn't
her character like helped progress the
story my note says one word flamethrower
she is such a badass
and that chase scene was so excited I
felt myself getting attached to these
characters that again there was no like
buildup of who they are you did right
you're straight and you know they're
archetypes that their place that they
are yeah but then they they play those
characters so well they you don't care
the end you know it like you know you're
like alright good I know these
characters now let's go totally she get
into very very mild spoilers I at one
point one of the characters passes away
and I was like touched and they were sad
about that and then that turns into a
really creepy and so well done sequence
um that was just yeah the whole time I
was just like I kept like very loudly
breathing out I don't think I just like
anything about this yeah no I really
didn't I have no complaints really do
you just want to go see buddy kind of do
a shot of espresso yeah my face yeah get
bacon thank you so much for watching
everyone go see this movie it is amazing
playing Wolfenstein you can see next
week
you